the Joe Rogan experience my brother's an
artist my brother's an artist so I kinda
art a fine art but also paints and he
teaches history of art so I I've had
this sort of baptism my whole life being
exposed to him I'm that you know the the
sibling scientist but the they have an
artist in the family I this everyone
should have an artist and family I've
got an uncle and of course the the whole
steam movement science technology
engineering and math the artist got in
they say wait slow stem the stem
movements nice no any man they want to
throw in the a to get art as part of
that movement science technology
engineering art and math change it from
stem to steam its esteem so you get full
steam ahead steam is a better word in
that well they both good words for what
they need but that just sounds like a
bunch of awesome stuff like it does and
yeah I'm not throwing comedy and it's
like the lbgtq a really squirrely when
you start adding more letters yeah you
can add letters but if it doesn't spell
anything then the memorization has to
kick in but steam you don't have to
memorize that it's already there for you
so it's cleverly conceived I think it
the abbreviation was its tacit
recognition that these are elements in
society that advance civilization and
and grow the economy actually so in fact
there's hardly any growth economy in the
world that isn't growing because it has
been frettin not having been touched by
science or technology everything just
think about it so if you're around
running you don't have them on your show
but if you run around saying I don't
like science science is bad science is
evil okay well then you will die in
poverty if you elect officials who
believe that as well who the [ __ ] thinks
that science is bad in 2019 and how do
they express this they express it
through sign okay so you know I'm saying
like are they saying it online I have a
book coming out in a month called
letters from an astrophysicist okay yeah
it's it's not it's not out yet I've got
it it's not how did you get a copy but I
don't even have my copy yet
what I'm saying in there I there's a
whole chapter on just angry people who
don't like anything including science
and one of them it's a it's a it's a
riff he just said I hate it and it signs
it and that science that brings some of
the worst things that's ever happened to
humanity and pollution and this he goes
on and on and on and on and on and so I
reply his letters from a national fizzes
and I and I reply as calmly and as
rationally as as possible when you get
attacked that way but what I'm saying is
not everyone embraces everything that
science does and some will cherry-pick
it you have the science deniers for a
global warming of science deniers with
vaccines you have science and IRAs with
GMOs you know there's there's all manner
of science denying going on in modern
society and you know we in a free
society what are you gonna do right that
people can think what they want but if
if thinking what they want influences
policy which then affects everybody then
your science denial has consequences to
the economic health of the nation and by
the way it's not only economics it's
your the economic health
it's your physical health because
medicine flows through advances in
science as well as our security well
there's people that deny some aspects of
science while conveniently using other
that's where it gets weird right you're
driving a car that's relying on GPS
you're using a phone to complain about
the global warming hoax you know you're
correct what one of my more more sort of
popular tweets was remember when they we
had the photo of the black hole from a
distant galaxy and it was banner
headlines maybe a year ago less than a
year ago banner headlines and first
photo ever of a black hole and it was an
astounding engineering achievement to
accomplish that it was multiple
telescopes all around the world pooling
the data to get it right and it was one
of the greatest collaborative efforts
we've ever undertaken in my field of
astrophysics
okay and everybody was loving the
results so all I tweeted was scientists
report first photo of a black hole
public
scientists report humans are warming the
earth
oh no you brought it up ok scientists we
produce the first-ever image of a
supermassive black hole 55 million light
years away the response scientist we've
concluded that humans are catastrophic
Li warming the earth response that
conflicts with what I want to be true so
it must be false well that is the
cherry-picking of science it is the
cherry-picking assignments but the
global warming thing is very much
connected to a certain type of ideology
a certain type of person thinks to the
doesn't matter to me
no nonsense person what I'm saying yes
it does matter what I'm what I'm trying
to say is that is a demographic that has
cherry-picked science to deny
human-caused global warming there are
other Democratic demographics said of
cherry-picked other science to deny
other things and it's not all located in
one political spectrum I mean one
political branch right so you tend to
find liberal folk complaining that the
conservatives who have embraced know the
glueten of global warming platform are
denying science and they need science on
their side
and many of those same people are
rubbing crystals together to be healed
by the crystal energy or they're denying
vaccines thinking that there's somehow
bad for you and so so all of this
requires sum or total rejection of
mainstream science and we're living in
that world now and I don't know I don't
think it'll stop the progress of
civilization but it can certainly slow
it down and occasionally stall it well
that is certainly a problem but how big
of a problem is it like how many people
are really in denial of science in 2019
it's got to be for me in a free country
that's not what matters what matters is
in a free country that you elect
officials who are not official yes you
you elect people who are scientifically
literate yeah they don't have to be
scientists I or and if they're not
scientifically literate they should be
self-aware of that and then listen to
people who are right so don't you think
what they're doing though is
there they're doing what their
constituents would like them to do
that's why I don't beat politicians over
the head ever I don't do that we're
we're we're Republic we're democracy
whatever they believe if they think
earth is 6,000 years old and they got
elected it's because the people elected
them believe there's he earth is 6,000
years old or because they're willing to
let that one go because they believe in
Oh possibly that's a good point because
you have a portfolio of thoughts and
beliefs or because he's such a profound
Christian I mean he's so profoundly
Christian plenty of leaders who are
connected to science that don't
including the Pope by the way you know
can you get more Christian than the Pope
all right he believes in science now
this new pope is pretty interesting yeah
if you read if you read his encyclical
from a couple of years ago it's it's
it's a scientifically literate doc
document yeah
and know this okay so it's not he's
still religious right so Jesus still
rose from the dead and there was still
miracles and all the rest of that in the
New Testament so he's not in denial of
that but given that he is saying oh my
gosh here's something we the religious
community and scientists can partner
behind and that if we want to save life
on Earth and so we have to be better
shepherds of what is going on on this
earth and one of them is we don't want
to flood low-lying countries in the
South Pacific where the average sea
level is 10 feet above sea level or
whatever it is you're gonna lose these
countries if you keep melting
our-our-our the
nothing ice caps because that would
include a north and there's no land in
the north so the glacier ice that's
land-based ice right because any ice
that's in the water floating that can
melt and it's not going to change the
water level so